and speaking of joss i know that
you both tried to go the traditional
route by contacting agents and managers
maybe you had an imdb pro account and
got those names when you said you met
joss somehow it was like divine
intervention in a parking lot after a
meeting other than jaws who who else did
you meet in an unconventional way and
what were some of the answers that these
gatekeepers gave you when you asked for
access
um
we
there's a couple of people
the way we got to everybody was
kind of different yeah mike kelly um we
went to
the paley fest we're doing a revenge
evening or afternoon um panel thing and
we tried to basically hijack them
outside on the red carpet line um
some people we met at different kind of
writing events around la as well um
um wherever you wherever we kind of
thought somebody might be i think jane
espenson we caught at a nerdist writer's
event as well um and some people a lot
of people we actually kind of got
through through the assistance
uh who were like very responsive to we
we cut a little piece together which had
a couple of the first people that we had
on camera and we released that just kind
of within industry here and a lot of the
assistants kind of picked that up and
spread it around
so
it got to be a little easier when we
were calling people that when i started
to explain what it was they kind of had
seen something and kind of had an
understanding of it and and that then
started to snowball a little bit once we
got one person another person or
whatever but
everybody was kind of different i'm
trying to think i mean jj took the
longest he was a year and a half
to get him but
to um was your pitch long or short sorry
to interrupt
were you besides showing the clip did
you kind of just um
you know we had a verbal spew where we
just lashed out every name we could
think of in about 15 seconds to people
saying is this in relation to joss when
we pitched or yeah or anybody
yeah well it's interesting because you
know when dez first came out and pitched
the idea i'm like oh wow you know
that's a great idea how are we going to
do this you know
and many people up to that point had was
trying to encourage him like you know
you might want to temper your
expectations this is going to be very
difficult if not impossible um you know
to get one let alone the breadth of the
scope that you need to tell a complete
story
but the problem actually quickly became
how are we going to get these very
important very busy people to
oh my god dez how are we going to fit
them all in because now they're coming
to us
in in their instances where like we had
show owners basically ringing us up um
because what happens is this is a very
monastic existence that they live and
they they only interact with certain
individuals in their writers room or in
their lives and we discovered that you
know the writers rooms talk to each
other and
the word spread very quickly after the
trailer landed in like oh my god they
got damon lindelof and why am i not in
this film and you know not exactly but
i'm paraphrasing why don't i have this
cool enough yeah
yeah um and
it is once you know damon kind of landed
in
we he was gracious enough to permit us
an interview and we were able to cut
that industry kind of clip together and
put it out as a teaser and trailer a
couple of years ago that really
made it a lot easier because then we had
something to show and it gave us
some some sort of credibility yeah
you